[Music]
well good morning everyone I'm really
excited to be here today to share with
you how we've used Google cloud platform
to analyze genomic data so a little bit
about myself I'm Christine and I lead a
team of software engineers and Byron
fermentations at myriad as a hybrid team
we're not just interested in analyzing
genomic data but we're also interested
in choosing the right tools to do so
especially in a clinical lab setting of
our size so first of all who are we we
are a genetic testing lab with a mission
to deliver genomic information to
patients at each stage of their life so
this requires a deep understanding of
technology across many different domains
so for example we need to have a deep
understanding of genomic data to
understand how to choose the right tools
to gather and structure genomic data
interpret it and then ultimately deliver
the right information to patients so
that's kind of from a mission standpoint
from a product standpoint we have three
different products for genomic
delivering genomic information to
patients at different stages of life so
our first test is our carrier screening
test this is for couples who are
planning on getting pregnant and want to
know if they are both carriers for a
recessive disease so we can screen for
over 200 inherited recessive conditions
including cystic fibrosis spinal
muscular atrophy and fragile X our
prenatal test is for women who are
pregnant and this test detects fetal
chromosomal abnormalities as early as 10
weeks into the pregnancy this replaces
and sensitive ultrasounds and also
invasive amniocentesis and finally our
inherited cancer screening test is for
men and women and it tests for bracha
one bracha two related breast and
ovarian cancers as well as several other
types of inherited cancers so to get a
sense of scale this is a broad market
with growing demand
there are currently 4.2 million pregnant
women in the United
States annually and we've really only
reached the tip of the iceberg in terms
of delivering genetic information to
them with a fifth of them receiving
carrier screening tests and a third of
them receiving non-invasive prenatal
testing the market for inherited cancer
screening is even larger with more
opportunities for growth with 19 million
women who meet criteria for inherited
cancer screening and only 1.5 of them
actually receiving preventative testing
so how do we do this we're a clinical
lab and how do we actually test these
patients for these different diseases so
it turns out like the typical flow of a
sample is actually quite similar across
all of our products we essentially
receive a tube of blood or saliva from
the patient and then we sequence the
sample in our lab depending on those
product we sequence we will do either
high coverage targeted sequencing or low
coverage whole genome sequencing after
sequencing is complete we align the
reads to the reference genome and look
for variance in that samples genome
after going through QC it then moves
into the variant interpretation phase
variant interpretation is the step that
is to determine which variants are
disease-causing or not not all variants
are actually disease-causing and so we
need to find the ones that are and
actually calculate risk as well in this
step so finally once we have all of the
interpreted information we are ready to
send the report to the patient so in
this talk I'm going to focus on how we
use GC p2 for the problem of variant
interpretation so just let's so first
let's talk about some of the challenges
of variant interpretation the challenges
of rendering variant interpretation are
come in two different flavors
one is the scalability flavor and then
the other is the diverse set of
information that we need to interpret
variants so to really understand the
challenge of variant interpretation we
first need to understand the scale of
the problem so how much data are we
dealing with
so myriad as myriad we are the largest
molecular diagnostics
company and we have tested over two
million patients to date all of our
tests are focused which means that we
test specific genes and diseases that we
have predetermined are actionable each
product we test a different set of genes
and diseases but in total and we test
for over 200 genes and diseases so what
does this mean in terms of base pair
sequence it again this depends on our
product but we can think of on average
sequencing around 1 million base pairs
per person some of our tests do low
coverage whole genome sequencing and
some of our other tests have a smaller
region of interest but on average we
will sequence around 1 million base
pairs per person so on the database
level what does this mean we need to
keep track of all of the sequence the
region sequenced in a person so to kind
of like blow that into perspective we
want to keep track of the 1 million
times 2 million base pairs that we've
ever sequenced in the lab we also want
to keep track of the variants that we
see per person so most of the time the
genomic sequence of a person is the same
as the average person variability and
humans are estimated to be 1 in 1,000
base pairs so a naive database
representation of the number of variants
that we see per person would be a
million divided by a thousand which is
1,000 variants per person multiplied by
the two million patients that we have
tested or two billion rows so so that's
kind of that gives you an idea of the
amount of sequencing data that we need
to keep track of for variant
interpretation we are we want to know
what the number of novel variants are
because we want to determine for each of
area and whether or not it's
disease-causing or not
so this graph just shows that even
though you've been testing for a while
there is a long tail of rare variants
that exist a vast majority of these
variants are benign but a small
percentage actually break the function
that they are in and we the problem of
variant interpretation is to determine
which one of these are disease-causing
or not so this kind of gives you an idea
of the scale of the problem but we need
to understand the other challenge which
is the many different
factors that are used to determine the
classification of a variant so for each
novel variant we need to determine if
it's disease-causing or not by gathering
and weighing different types of evidence
so you don't actually have to read this
but these are guidelines that are
produced by the American Society of
medical genetics that just show the
multiple types of evidence that one
needs to consider when determining the
classification of a variant I'm gonna
just highlight one of these types of
evidence it which is allele frequency
knowing the allele frequency can really
help determine the pathogenicity of the
variant because if we see this allele
occur more often than the disease itself
occurs then it is less likely to be a
pathogenic variant and so you can
classify this allele as benign if it has
a high allele frequency so what is
allele frequency it's pretty
straightforward it's calculated as a
fraction the number of times that we see
in a Leo in a population over the number
of times that this particular locus of
the allele was sequenced in the
population this is very least rate this
is fairly straightforward but just want
to highlight that we need to parse a lot
of genomic data to get this calculation
so we need four for AC which is the
wheel count we need to go through all of
the calls of every sample to calculate
this and for a n which is the number of
times that we've sequenced a particular
locus we need to go through all of the
regions being sequenced in every single
sample so that's a lot of genomic data
another type of evidence is as i
gossiped 'i count so zygosity count is
similar to wheel frequency and that it's
counting the number of times a certain
genotype is seen in a population so
since humans are diploid we have two
copies of each of our chromosome one is
from our mom then one is reminder so
most people are the same as the
reference genome and so that makes them
homozygous for the reference sequence
some people have a mutation on one copy
of their chromosome making them
heterozygous and sometimes a person has
a mutation on both copies of their
chromosome making them homozygous for
the alternate sequence
and in some rare cases a person actually
only has one copy of the chromosome at a
particular locus making them what we
call a hemizygous
so for variant interpretation we're
really interested in knowing the
zygosity count because if several people
are homozygous for the alternate
sequence then that is that makes this
allele less likely to be disease-causing
all of these questions really fall under
a class of analyses called tertiary
analysis where we try to make sense of
sequencing data so just to contrast
between primary analysis which is really
trying to interpret the data that's
coming off of the sequencing machines
and output sequencing reads and
contrasted with secondary analysis which
aims to assemble and align the reads to
a genome and call variants tertiary
analysis tries to make sense of this
variation in a biological way so other
types of questions that we may want to
ask when we're doing tertiary analysis
would be how often do we see a
combination of alleles together in one
patient we also might want to calculate
these metrics on different segments of
the population so we may want to segment
by ethnicity for example sometimes an
allele can have a high frequency and one
ethnicity but not others and that would
give it enough evidence to classify it
as benign we may also want a segment by
gender because there are some diseases
like cystic fibrosis that have different
outcomes for gender and so you might
want to segment look only at the female
population if you want to assume a
healthy population again we also we
always when calculating these metrics we
do want to have assumed that we have a
healthy population so we potentially
want to sequence out any patients with
any sort of testing indication that's
not routine carrier screening that means
that they might be getting tested for a
particular reason and they are probably
actually like not considered to be part
of the healthy population furthermore
for research purposes we really want to
make sure that we are only including
samples I have consented to research
are in research allowed jurisdictions so
this is another type of segmentation of
population that we are interested in in
the research realm finally tertiary
analysis does not need to be limited to
variant interpretation we may for
example want to infer ethnicity of
patients based on their genetic
information and we can and this is this
falls under the remote area analysis so
for a lot of these questions we can
utilize public databases we can see as a
variant has been observed in that
particular population and look at what
the allele frequency and the zygosity
are in that population but some caveats
are that these populations databases are
often limited in size which means that
rare variants are less likely to be
observed and if they aren't observed
they may have a good chance of being
over-represented furthermore we aren't
actually able to answer some questions
like co-occurrence without knowing the
genotype at an individual level so we do
use these healthy data sets but these
are just like one type of evidence that
we consider really in order to provide
the best information to our patients we
have to leverage our own internal data
set of over two million patients with
this larger population we have much more
statistical power for variant
interpretation and we can also go beyond
variant interpretation and contribute
back to science and do our own
retrospective analyses so again when
we're doing research we have to be very
careful making sure that our samples
have been consented for research and our
research in research allow jurisdictions
but once we have that population then we
can for example ask questions like what
is our carrier rate to understand more
of the efficacy of expanded carrier
screening especially in a diverse like a
diverse ethnic population so what is the
carrier rate what is the address couple
rate those are all very interesting
questions to basically prove efficacy of
our tests with this platform we can also
observe other patterns such as coupling
patterns across ethnicities
and we can observe many other types of
these analyses with the data that we
have so hopefully this so really
hopefully like this motivates building a
system for tertiary analysis that
requires tackling two major challenges
the first one is scalability and the
second is flexibility
we need a flexible system because unlike
clinical trials or other hypothesis
different projects the set of mated
metadata that might be relevant for
analysis is diverse and potentially
unknown upfront so for example I can ask
to see all of the homozygous individuals
that have a co-occurring pathogenic
mutation a one group may want to see a
certain set of metadata for variant
interpretation and another group may
want to see another set of metadata for
retrospective analysis furthermore
different groups may have different
restrictions and access to data so we
really need a solution that allows for
flexible ad hoc aggregation and cyber
filtering of variant information along
with sample metadata we also need a
scalable system we have a very large
population data set and this population
data set is growing every single day so
unlike some of the public databases or
academic cohorts this is a patient
population that is growing every single
day and we need to calculate these
metrics on the latest information so I
just wanted to talk about one
implementation that we had before using
bigquery so we essentially hand-built a
batch compute with Luigi to calculate
allele frequencies this pipeline was
very optimized for the one metric that
it needed to calculate we basically took
advantage of the fact that this was a
recursive procedure and stored the
previous days a CA and AF and would add
to that as needed as we got new samples
every single day
but some of the problems and that we ran
into was that it was not flexible so if
we wanted to add another metric we had
to build a completely different pipeline
and these would often take weeks to run
on all of our historical data we could
obviously like increase the instance
size and the compute power but it would
still be very compute-intensive
the other thing is that it's really not
able to do like ad hoc aggregation and
filtering you really have to be thinking
about what is the information that you
want upfront and then and then building
the pipeline to calculate it so it's
very it's not a very flexible system
it's not scalable in the sense that we
aren't able to really generate these
metrics in an ad hoc way with the amount
of data that we have in the time that
scientists need to see them in real time
so that's kind of motivates why we
decided to look into using bigquery so
this is just a very high-level
architectural overview of our system we
have genomic data and sample data that
is stored on the on Google Cloud storage
this is based this is ingested into
bigquery using data flow and then right
now we have just a very simple system
that persists the results back into
cloud storage so as new data comes in
new we add new rows to bigquery so let
me just go into each of the individual
steps so this is the input data that
we're dealing with we store genomic data
and sample data I will go into a little
bit more detail about what the genomic
data looks like the sample data is kind
of anything that you might want to know
about the sample so that would be gender
ethnicity the testing indications family
history etc and for the genomic
information
we store this in a format called G VCF
so if you work with genomic data you may
be familiar with the concept of VCF
which is the variant call format this is
a file that basically contains all of
the call information for a particular
sample a genomic VCF is very similar to
the VCF in but it also includes the
homozygous reference regions so
essentially this allows us to
distinguish between regions that were
sequenced and regions that were not and
so you can see that there are like large
blocks of homozygous reference regions
in this particular sample that indicates
that this person was sequenced here but
no variants were called here so then
okay so so we have all of this
information genomic information and
sample information in our Google Cloud
storage the next thing we want to do is
transform and load this into bigquery so
the way that we chose to do this was we
chose to parse the GBCs into and
transform them into a parquet format
with this we're able to really be
flexible about the schema that we we
want and that we want in bigquery and
and we're able to and then at the end of
the day we have these part K files that
we could potentially use in other areas
and other like cloud systems as well so
we parse our GVCS
every single sample transform them into
park' and then append the new samples to
our bigquery table and similarly we do
this with a sample metadata so this is
an example of what the bigquery table
ends up looking like after we load it in
with data flow as you can see it's very
similar to the G VCF that I showed
earlier it has you know your chromosome
position graph alt and the genotype
information available so now I'll just
kind of go this is kind of a high-level
overview of a sample query so to
calculate allele count we split this up
into two steps really the first is to
parse the genotype field so that every
single row represents a single allele
for a sample
and then after we do this after we
flatten at the table we are able to
aggregate all the alleles together to
generate the LDL count and so this is
kind of a so-so this is like a simple
group buy and then and then account and
aggregate so I wanted to talk a little
bit about some of the tricky cases that
we have dealt with because on the
surface level this may seem like very
straightforward to do but there are some
tricky edge cases that we have to deal
with and one of them is the
deduplication of samples so there's a
possibility that patients can get tested
multiple times in our lab and so as a
result there can be multiple samples
that are associated with a particular
patient and we want to use the most
recent sample because those are assumed
to be the most accurate in our previous
pipeline in fermentation we had to do
this by calculating them at since we
were calculating the metrics
incrementally we had to basically
subtract out the counts of the samples
that were duplicate and and and append
that to append the subtraction to our
final allele count but with bigquery you
can kind of do it it's like much easier
to duplicate the samples upfront and
then kind of recompute your metrics so
the other tricky case that I wanted to
talk about is the deduplication of
alleles and bigquery we often define
there can be multiple representations of
the same allele so when working with
genomic data we often define alleles in
according to the reference sequence but
as you guys may know there are many
versions of the reference genome and
even with the same reference genome
there are potentially multiple
representations in very repetitive
regions so this particular example is an
example of an insertion deletion and in
Dell in a repetitive region of the
genome and you can see that there are
potentially four different
representations of this allele when
compared to the reference genome so this
is a known problem in the field of
genomics there are many groups out many
working groups out there one
and the Global Alliance for genomic
health that are dedicated to solving
this problem so how we've decided to
address this problem is very similar to
the way that Global Alliance for genomic
health has also addressed it by using a
content-addressable hash so this is an
internally built library that we built
that can is used to tag alleles up front
so then we'll tag them with the hash and
then come and then it makes it much
easier to combine ovules later and the
bigquery pipeline and then so finally
the the real advantage of bigquery is
this continuous ingestion of data we're
able to essentially just add rows to the
bakery table as we see more samples
coming through our lab and because it's
so easy to query on this we can kind of
we can just recompute our metrics on the
entire table so how do we so then how do
we actually add more genomic
calculations in bigquery it's as simple
as writing another sequel query so we
can do this and do this for
co-occurrence zygosity and dependent
samples furthermore this putting it in
bigquery allows us to do a lot of ad hoc
filtering and segmentation we can filter
and segment on ethnicity and gender
testing indication etc and so this
really allows us the scalability that we
were looking for and the flexibility
that we were looking for in terms of ad
hoc filtering so to kind of wrap up I
wanted to talk about application in
cystic fibrosis cystic fibrosis is one
of the most common autosomal recessive
conditions according to ACOG it's caused
by a mutation in the CFTR gene which
codes for the CFTR protein CFTR protein
acts as a channel on the the membranes
of the cells to control for the flow of
water and ions in and out of the cell
especially in the lung so if there's the
pathogenic mutation
on both chromosomes this will cause
cystic fibrosis it does this by
basically reducing the flow of these
ions and and as a result there's a thick
mucus that tends to form on the surface
at the cells so this causes lung
infections and limits the ability to
breathe over time so as a carrier
screening lab we have the advantage of
having a very large healthy population
so with this very large healthy
population we're actually able to use
our internal data to reclassify some
variants that we previously did not have
enough evidence to classify and as a
result they were considered variants of
unknown significance variants of unknown
significance are just variants that
we've exhausted all the information we
know about this but we still don't know
whether or not it's disease-causing or
not these types of variants makes it
really difficult to counsel patients
because it's obviously better to know
definitively what are the whether it's
benign or pathogenic so this particular
variant we wanted to know how many
patients have this allele along with
another pathogenic variant if this
particular allele occurs very often with
another pathogenic variant it's much
less likely that this is actually a
pathogenic variant because the fact that
we have a healthy population means that
these people are alive and well and they
they don't have cystic fibrosis so we
asked that question and it turns out
that there were quite a few people that
had a co-occurring mutation with a
pathogenic mutation but then we wanted
to go a little bit further so cystic
fibrosis is an interesting disease and
that there is variable phenotype for
males and so it's very likely that there
may be males with cystic fibrosis I
don't even know it and so to filter out
the males and just look at the number of
co-occurring pathogenic mutations in a
female population that gives us a much
stronger statistical power to classify
this variant as been
and ultimately we were able to do that
we were able to downgrade this variant
to benign this is another example where
we actually did not have enough
information to downgrade so we asked the
question how many patients has this
co-occurring mutation has this mutation
co-occurring with a pathogenic mutation
and the conclusion was that there was
not enough to downgrade and then finally
for this particular variant we also were
able to reclassify it but we actually
reclassified it from pathogenic to the
u.s. given the answers to some of these
questions we actually think it's
probably benign but the fact that we're
not giving a false positive to a patient
is actually very like is is better than
that so to downgrade this Ferenc we
actually use both allele frequency and
co-occurring statistics to to downgrade
so it turns out that this allele
actually occurs quite a lot in a healthy
patient population so it's considered to
be very like a very strong candidate for
actually being benign
[Music]